you know a lot of people are talking
about AI it's a concern we got climate
change oh my God this is the end of the
world nuclear war but very few people
are talking about actual shortage of
food according to the economist in the
next 40 years we will need to produce
more food in the next four years than we
have in the previous 10 000 years
combined in one of the industries that a
lot of people are talking about is
called vertical farming matter of fact a
guy named Elon Musk his brother Kimball
is now a farmer investing into vertical
farming Let's Get Right In
[Music]
foreign
by the way if you get value from this
video at the end give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel let's get right
into it you know what's crazy is I'm a
Fort Lauderdale right now we had a big
flood 22 inches of rain in Fort Lauder
the record break and everybody's talking
about it for a couple days there is no
gas in Miami everybody is calling and I
can't fill up the tank how am I going to
come up to Fort Lauderdale I got to
drive up people are panicking just
because there was no gas for one day in
Miami Gas Stations were all sold out
right so maybe say Pat what's your point
there what would you do if you didn't
have food for one day about two days
three days think about that shortage
what happens when you're at a hotel or
your place the bathroom doesn't work you
can't use the bathroom there's flooding
what do you think about that stress goes
from something you never think about all
of a sudden to something massive right
that's exactly what the concern is with
food shortage I'll give you a stat here
food production needs to increase by
roughly 70 percent by 2050 to support
the expected 10 billion world population
and that's only 27 years from now so now
let's look at a bunch of different data
here and see if this is something we
ought to be thinking about the things
we'll look at today is air Global land
we'll look at topsoil fresh water supply
we'll look at benefits of vertical
farming Solutions different types how
they do it cost of it what different
companies are doing today and then at
the end I want to get your thoughts if
this is something we ought to be
concerned about and potentially how big
of an industry this is going to be by
2030 wait till you see the numbers let's
get right into it arable land is land
capable of being used to grow crops so
now arable land is down 30 since the
1970s it is expected to drop another 60
percent from the current number by 2050.
so it's already down 30 since the 70s
and it's expected to drop another 60
between now and 2050 27 years from now
now let's look at different regions
worldwide Australia Canada us look at
this number here this chart far left is
Australia dark blue is 1975. Light blues
85 that orange color is 95 and then the
yellow one is 2005. Australia is down 20
percent of arable land because we're
building more buildings Canada is down
25 percent Russia is now 17 percent U.S
is down 32 percent the benefit of
capitalism we're building a lot of
different places but at the same time
the arable land is going to be cut as
well right so you got Brazil down 16.
India's down 45 because India just is
getting into capitalism their economy is
growing they got a lot of different
things so why is this a concern if we
have we have our arable lands that's
decreasing at the pace that it is just
in four years of this charge well the
next one is about topsoil topsoil is the
primary resource for plants to grow and
crops to thrive each year an estimated
24 billion tons of fertile soil are lost
due to erosion which is 25 the total
land area has been degraded so when you
look at this map here you see what it's
looking like very degraded soil degraded
soil stable soil and without vegetation
these are some things that people are
sitting there thinking saying we may not
be worried about it today but this could
be a big issue for us within the next 27
years and this leads to water because we
also need water fresh water supply
agriculture currently use uses roughly
70 percent of the global fresh water
supply Irrigation in other words only
one to three percent of water on Earth
is fresh water pesticides and
fertilizers and other toxic from
chemicals can poison fresh water so if
you look at this here where is the water
on Earth you'll see 97.2 percent is
Oceans you got a small percentage there
2.15 percent as glaciers and a 0.65
percent that is groundwater lakes and
rivers soil moisture and atmosphere so
we also need this so so far we got what
arable land we got top soil we got fresh
water supply all of these things are
leading to a concern of what we're going
to do if we have a shortage of food over
the next 27 years so now farming
problems let's look at these so for
those of us that are not farmers and
maybe you didn't grow up on a farm
you're like okay why is this such a
concern I don't know any of this stuff
these are the traditional farming
problems and why a lot of people are
starting to consider vertical farming so
let's look at the problems traditional
Farmers have number one tillage
negatively impacts soil quality it
fractures the soil disrupts soil
structure accelerate service runoffs and
soil erosion that's number one if you're
a farmer you know exactly what we're
talking about where you have to move
them this leads to the next one the
government pays Farmers to limit crop
growth to put a price floor in place so
farmers can stay in business number
three irrigation is highly inefficient
number four unpredictable weather number
five insects and it's limited to only
portions of the Year fertilizer
dependent on last but not least
chemicals and pesticide there is a
timeline for this this is why it's not
sustainable for us to go this way long
term now vertical farming if you look at
it came about in 1999 when this
professor from Columbia University Dixon
this home year he's a professor of
Environmental Health Sciences and 105
graduate students were exploring methods
to address this problem and came up with
the concept of vertical farming a
multi-story building grown layers of
crops on each floor pretty common sense
for us to be like if you and I were
thinking about this you're like we
probably should have known this 100
years ago 1999 is when we thought about
what if we go this way well I kind of
cool you think about effect if you look
at some of these videos that we're
showing you this is called vertical
farming this is what Elon musk's brother
Kimball got involved in so now the
benefits of vertical farming here's what
it is no soul required which alleviates
the topsoil problem requires 99 less
water and fertilizer can grow year round
no pesticides occupies 99 less space
because you're simply going up can be
placed in cities cutting the burden of
long Transportation so you may say Pat
who cares about Transportation here's
why current the average distance of farm
food transportation is 1500 miles 68 of
people live in cities far from Farms
fruit and vegetables lose up to 50
percent of nutrients from Farm to store
and less carbon emissions from
Transportation there you go that's the
benefit because you can put it anywhere
you can literally put it in New York
City if you wanted to you can put it in
Miami in LA in Beverly Hills right there
and then boom deliver it to the people
in Beverly Hills so now different types
of vertical farming there's three types
Hydroponics this is where plants grow in
water or growing medium with nutrients
delivered directly to their Roots
Hydroponics the largest segment and
account for more than 45 percent share
of vertical farming in 2021 aeroponics
uses a Mist to deliver nutrients to
plant fruits and then you have
aquaponics which fish are raised and
their waste is used as nutrients for
crops creates a loop system where the
fish feed the plants and the plants feed
the fish so now you mix a pan why are
more people doing this but because it's
a great idea it's exciting but it's
expensive this is what they haven't yet
figured out so high Capital requirement
to start facilities require a lot of
energy growing grains like corn and
wheat have been a challenge so now when
you think about this and you're thinking
the current method they're not your
nuclear they're currently doing it the
traditional way the simulated yields
revealed that vertical farming could
produce 600 times the current world
average wheat yield in their study the
authors describe how compared with
traditional farming methods in outdoor
Fields indoor vertical farming also
requires less land area water herbicide
guides and pesticides and result in less
nutrient loss to the environment but
there's got to be incentive so if the
capitalist and a job Creator sitting
there and there's notice and the margins
are like this you can't really get the
big Capital into it but the moment
somebody figures out how to do it and
not have to use up all the energy
whether they choose to do through
nuclear or another form of affordable
energy this could be an industry a lot
of people may get involved in in no time
okay because again the upside is
essentially unlimited because the upside
is unlimited right so now some creative
ways they can do to maybe cut costs
right this is the one thing we talked
about earlier what people fear AI being
one of them this is where AI can
actually help solve this problem that
they're facing so number one using AI
that can cut labor costs they can
operate 24 7. AI can operate on a cloud
connected Network monitor soil Health AI
can conduct chemical analysis machine
learning algorithms use data to optimize
the automated system drones make it more
feasible to monitor high up sections
able to be programmed to move move in
preset paths around the Farms if they're
able to do those types of things you
save a little bit of money if they can
use affordable energy the rest is
history so let's look at what Elon
musk's brother Kimball is up to with
this company called square roots if you
look at these containers you see how
they're on top of each other it's a very
interesting model because one of these
320 square foot containers can produce
as much as a one to two acre traditional
outdoor farm barely using any water and
by the way there's so much applications
people wanted one of these containers
there's people right now making thirty
thousand dollars part-time doing this
they're flooded with applications but
this is one of the companies out there
that's doing this there's a couple out
there right now the top vertical farming
companies one of them is agricool uh
revenue of 103 million that's very small
the other one is Bowery farming 83
million dollars Freight Farms 72 million
dollars Aero Farms 22 million dollars
and it's estimated if you look at this
industry by 2030 this could be a 25 to a
26 billion dollar industry people are
just realizing this so watch this what I
just presented to you how are you
receiving this content so use your
reason logic and the level of skepticism
what area are you skeptical about think
about you're like no this kind of makes
sense this is logical so this is where
entrepreneurs come in and solve The
World's problems through Innovation
that's vertical farming this is why I
trust in capitalism because there's
incentive to solve many of the problems
we're dealing with today so thoughts
concerns comments below if you got value
from this video give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel I did a video
four years ago titled how to disrupt any
industry if you've never seen it before
click here to watch it take everybody
bye-bye bye-bye
thank you